mais que fait donc cette jeune fille
avec un pistolet mitrailleur deux mois
et demi après le débarquement de
normandie
elle pose pour un photographe américain
sa silhouette surprend sa jeunesse
interpelle août 44 chartres vient d'être
libéré par les amis la photo de cette
jeune femme à la mitraillette a fait le
tour du monde simone segouin depuis
plusieurs mois agent de liaison à 96 ans
simone segouin est toujours de ce monde
mais trop fatigué pour témoigner un
historien local nous montre sa maison
natale une ferme modeste où son père
communiste avait des activités de
résistance
les allemands qui voulaient
réquisitionné simone jeune couturière
mais tel réseau en danger son père lui
demande de partir simone va être obligé
de prendre la clandestinité et c'est à
ce moment là qu'elle va être versée dans
un groupe ftp sous la direction de germa
ou son de son vrai nom roland boursiers
à 18 ans elle va effectuer des missions
de liaison pour les ftp ou chef lui
avait dit si tu veux pas faire partie de
la résistance
il faut un moyen de transport ils te
font à vélo va chercher un vélo et elle
est venue volé le vélo de l'allemande
donc elle peut au risque effectivement à
tout moment un contrôle
c'est quand même très très gonflé de
simone parcours tout le département au
nez et à la barbe des allemands et sous
les bombes
un nom elles transportent des armes et
des messages au risque de sa vie lors
d'une mission sabotage une nuit les
hommes du groupe tordre les rails
simonel à une autre tâche sa seule
mission c'est prévenir le chef de garde
pour empêcher un accident votre litre en
civil août 44
son groupe est appelé pour arrêter un
soldat allemand égaré dans le bois du
moulin de chalon simone et de
l'expédition
on est partis avec
deux camarades et la grosse surprise est
que quand on arrivait pour faire soit il
sort le prisonnier en avait 23
on les a tous des armées et c'est là que
j'ai que j'ai pris cette mitraillette
sur le dos d'un amant grâce à cette
photo de jack belden ce pistolet
mitrailleur va faire de simone segouin
un symbole de la résistance française
aux yeux des américains
elle sera la seule femme à défiler à
chartres devant de gaulle le 23 août
simone segouin fui les honneurs
longtemps elle n'avait même pas parler
de la guerre à ses six enfants et vient
de refuser la légion d'honneur
elle préfère le calme de sa maison de
retraite